[Música]
en eeuu se respira un ambiente de
tensión política de cara a las
elecciones de medio término que tendrán
lugar en noviembre una serie de
escándalos investigaciones que
involucran al ex presidente donald trump
podrían afectar a su partido en estos
comicios y a su candidatura para 2024
pues ya lo vamos a saber la última de
estas polémicas se tiene que ver con el
que el fbi recuperó documentos
clasificados y de alto secreto en la
residencia de abramson de mar a lago en
florida durante su registro del 8 de
agosto lo que apunta a la posible
violación de tres leyes federales por
parte del ex presidente a pesar de todas
estas causas pareciera que donald trump
no se está viendo para nada afectado
políticamente ya que en las primarias
republicanas los candidatos a los que
apoya han ganado mayoritariamente la más
reciente la victoria para el
exmandatario fue la derrota de la
representante liz cheney en el estado de
wyoming quien se convirtió en su más
férrea crítica en el congreso salvamos
entonces a esta hora rafael piñeros
experto en temas de eeuu y profesor de
relaciones internacionales en la
universidad externado de colombia rafael
un gusto tenerlo nuevamente con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24
muy buena mañana del miércoles vamos a
seguir entonces analizando la noticia
momento en eeuu la derrota listening
wyoming que demuestra esto entonces la
fuerza que sigue teniendo donald trump
dentro del partido republicano no en
efecto ha sido un expresidente difícil
de controlar es difícil desde el punto
de vista del estudio saber qué puede
hacer y qué va a hacer donald trump pero
al mismo tiempo es difícil porque los
resultados lo acompañan estoy casi que
seguro que una gran cantidad de personas
no está de acuerdo con el tipo de
liderazgo que ejerce donald trump sobre
el partido republicano pero es muy
difícil cuando en las elecciones se
presentan los resultados que se
presentaron anoche en el estado de
wyoming en el cual sin duda alguna pues
su más férrea opositora en la cámara de
representantes- vicepresidenta del
comité que investiga los hechos del 6 de
enero pues sale derrotada y sale
derrotada por un margen bastante amplio
no la diferencia fue de más de 30 puntos
si miramos de los 10 congresistas que
votaron en contra y que hacen parte del
partido republicano tan sólo dos han
obtenido una reelección 4 presentaron y
cuatro más perdieron entre ellos leasing
eso para demostrar cómo es ese carácter
como vengativo es el carácter que
buscaba directamente que ellos perdieran
pues lo viene alcanzando ahora no todos
son victorias para donald trump también
que mencionaron y en las elecciones de
alaska por ejemplo la ex candidata a la
vicepresidencia sarah palin
exgobernadora de alaska
perdió la elección que también era una
férrea defensora del presidente entonces
si bien son más las victorias que las
derrotas no necesariamente todo está
claro para el presidente de donald trump
en términos electorales también hablando
de elecciones raffaele se habla también
de la posibilidad de que se opte para
lanzarse a la presidencia en el año 2024
su discurso de la
derrota ayer tuvo un eco nacional no
también le preguntó si ya tendría
suficiente impulso suficiente fuerza
para poder truncar de las aspiraciones
de una reelección al presidente don atom
en el año 2024 bueno es bastante difícil
el panorama en el partido que no está en
el poder se torna a partir de la
diversidad de actores también suena
mucho
de la florida ron de santis y suenan
otros líderes del partido republicano
que poco a poco irán quemando sus
baterías ahora todo candidato o
precandidato tiene que tener una
fortaleza muy fuerte que es su estado y
recordemos que en el año 2020 el estado
de wyoming votó mayoritariamente por
donald trump el 70% del electorado votó
por donald trump y fue el estado en el
que tuvo una mayor diferencia respecto
al hoy presidente joe biden de tal forma
que no la tiene fácil porque en un corto
periodo de tiempo tendría que recuperar
las bases de wyoming si bien tiene una
buena entrada en otros estados y por
supuesto a nivel nacional eso no
necesariamente le asegura un claro
camino hacia la victoria se cree también
rafael que digamos o uno de los únicos
caminos para sacar a donald trump de la
contienda política para una reelección
de 74 es que sea inhabilitado bien sea
por lo que pasó el 6 de enero 2021 con
la toma del congreso o por estas
investigaciones que está haciendo el fbi
por los documentos clasificados qué
opinión le merece esto podría de verdad
donald trump ser inhabilitar
políticamente es muy difícil el sistema
legal estadounidense como muchos a nivel
mundial reconocen que una persona es
inocente hasta que se le demuestre lo
contrario son varios los delitos
federales no solo en esta intervención
sino en las otras desde el punto de
vista personal las que tienen que ver
con acoso sexual que siguen en pie las
que tienen que ver con su organización
es decir con la organización donald
trump delitos de evasión y elusión
fiscal y está que se abrió por la
posible mala utilización de documentos
federales reservados es cierto que el
departamento de justicia de los eeuu le
había solicitado en reiteradas
oportunidades al presidente que
devolviera información que debería ser
parte del archivo nacional y él se negó
y esa fue una de las razones que esgrime
el departamento de justicia para haberle
solicitado el fbi quisiera digamos una
especie de redada para ir a recuperar
ese material que el presidente era terco
y que quería mantener en su casa
sabiendo de antemano que estaba
prohibido también hay que mencionar que
un presidente de los eeuu puede
solicitar información a los archivos
nacionales cuando necesario y a través
de una carta que le envió al archivo
nacional y al departamento de justicia
un día antes de salir de la presidencia
se estableció que iba a encargar asustar
a sus abogados más cercanos para que
fueran a recolectar información mucha de
esa información sirvió para el
impeachment que durante el 2020 se le
llevó a cabo y que se convirtieron en
material probatorio en el proceso en la
cámara de representantes continuará han
sido muchos muchas las horas los
testimonios de más de 3.000 personas que
han testificado básicamente que el
presidente inició nada durante más de
tres horas del 6 de enero para evitar
que la situación llegara a lo que todos
conocemos y eventualmente podría haber
una puerta el problema es que no sabemos
qué delito federal lleva el presidente
incumplir porque ya ha incumplido
canarias la regla y esa es la situación
que preocupa y que preocupa no sólo las
bases de su partido sino el sistema
político en general nos vamos al otro
bando al bando demócrata de cómo llegan
a las elecciones con una popularidad del
presidente de byd en muy baja
preocupados
preocupados porque sin duda alguna los
resultados del presidente joe biden no
son tan malos pero son pésimas los
índices de popularidad y de
reconocimiento a su gestión y divididos
porque los demócratas su visión frente a
una situación aquellas personas de
ingresos bajos o medios se enferma
consideran que son los asuntos
económicos los que acaparan más la
atención sin embargo en ciudades
cosmopolitan en ciudades de más altos
ingresos son las decisiones judiciales
especialmente las decisiones de la corte
suprema de justicia las que han influido
para que masivamente salgan más
demócratas a votar demócrata es decir
por la defensa de los derechos mientras
que hay otro grupo importante también
especialmente de latinos y otras
comunidades de inmigrantes que observan
en que los asuntos económicos siguen
siendo la nota predominante en lo
económico no le va muy bien a bailén y
en la defensa de derechos puede tener
una oportunidad entonces los demócratas
se enfrentan a una situación compleja y
difícil en la cual las perspectivas para
el día de hoy es decir finales de agosto
y aparecen bastante sombrías porque
pueden perder el liderazgo de la cámara
de representantes y eventualmente del
senado lo cual sería catastrófico de
cara a las elecciones del 2024 hablando
de esas elecciones tenemos 20 segunditos
rafael del lado demócrata hay digamos
una figura prominente para poder ganarle
un eventual candidatura donald trump
pero tendría que decidirlo previamente
el presidente yo bailé porque es muy
difícil y disputarle el liderazgo el
presidente en ejercicio hoy quien manda
es joe biden y eventualmente él tendría
con suficiente tiempo esperemos que
las elecciones de noviembre pueden ser
un termómetro significativo para saber
si él tiene la fuerza de lanzarse a la
reelección claro cuál es peligroso
entrada porque le había dicho que iba a
ser un presidente de un término o si
después de las elecciones dice aquí pues
hay que darle paso a otros liderazgos
más jóvenes y de otro tipo rafael
lamentablemente se me acaba el tiempo en
otra oportunidad vamos a seguir hablando
de este tema estadounidense queda mucho
mucho por hablar a rafael piñero es
experto en temas de eeuu y profesor de
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad externado de colombia
nosotros continuamos esto es directo
américa